you guys you guys ever seen that clip of
Obama saying like yeah I mean if I could
just not be president and have somebody
just and I could pull the strings sounds
like Biden to me
[Music]
all right I want you guys to watch this
uh race
there's a Somali athlete that broke a
record at the world University games in
China it's gonna be this person right
there I bet he's gonna run faster than
ever she's um I'm not seeing this yeah
Somali right here the light blue just
keep your eyes try to follow this Runner
wait what
[Music]
what
okay the record for the slowest time so
she wasn't training at all huh oh man I
thought it was gonna be like a really
fast Somali me too Runner with a bunch
of Chinese people and then they're like
like getting that's right smoked
that looks like she's jogging at the end
run oh she didn't even look like she was
prepared for yeah no not a runner at all
dude it looks like she never sprinted
ever she never has
so I guess what happens in charge of
choosing who goes to the games just
picked like a relative
and they told her oh [__] you got to be
there tomorrow
yeah that's what happened
now there's a accusation of nepotism
from that like official
literally uh yeah that girl's not even a
runner at all that's the worst way to
get caught for nothing just put her on
they're like hey uh Bernice you want a
free trip to China yeah hey pretty you
just one run National Television Uncle
I'm having a hard time getting my Visa
okay you gotta do something for me you
want to study in uh Beijing University
that'll be like the first time that's
ever happened right because I can't
think of
I mean it could be the first time that
nepotism picked somebody as unqualified
as that right that's what I'm saying
yeah because usually it's like uh
they'll pick someone that can at least
blend in she wasn't ready at all or
there was one time that like uh in a
cool way there was like one country who
um their hurdler like got injured or
something like that so I had to pull out
but if you don't purchase if your
country doesn't participate then as a
team
um you don't get like the points for it
so one of the like uh shot put thrower
ladies she was like I'll just come in to
get that one point for the team so she
obviously had the slowest time but that
was like a commendable honorable way to
participate but at least it's an athlete
still imagine what that feels like to be
a Somali Runner that's really good oh
dude oh you couldn't get the job you
didn't qualify right I gotta be pissed
and then you watched the actual like
games and you're like wait her but guess
what now you got leverage dude now you
got leverage because you go hey you want
her to compete in the games next year
you're gonna put me in a game
you want to be embarrassed the bars like
this yeah yeah
baptism is a hell of a thing right it is
people get put into positions but don't
you want to hook up all your friends but
not if you know not if they're gonna
make me lose my job yeah because that
that's harmful for you you know like if
you're the person who gave them that job
that's a bad look that is true but I
feel like some places it's just so
corrupt and done that way that that's
normal so they don't even think about
like or maybe I should put the right
person in
you know what I mean like because it's
so normal like if you go if you live in
a country where it's so normal where you
get pulled over and you're like oh you
got a 20 all right give that to the cop
see ya
then following the rules is like you're
being weird it would be funny if like
that relative was like I didn't know he
was gonna run that slow
I'm all right like losing is losing sure
but like man you like the camera left
you yeah yeah what if she did yeah yeah
she was out of frame the other way what
if she ran track
and this is like 10 years later oh
oh that could be yeah she's like a
Beyond the Glory Days kind of person
it's like I could do it no she doesn't
like that
it's like when you call one of those
cars in Vegas that they're handing out
and the ending the ending skip where
she's like the arm for me yeah she's
like I'm [__] so tired and she grows
she's like oh my God I'm so tired yeah
dude like Somalia has like tons of like
great Runners it's like a I just known
for their Pirates really dude I don't
really think of it
I think those are two different oh is it
two different I think so one Somalia I
gotta look at Maps dude and I think
because I think there's two countries oh
the somalis is different than Somalia
check it though I might be wrong Czech
Republic or is that what they just kind
that I've check it though do they call
them somalis Somali the people of Africa
occupying all of Somalia
oh so that's what they thought they
split into two countries but I don't
know maybe some mommy Arab Somali Africa
and what's a sommelier
[Laughter]
[__] Nick is so funny so funny God put
in the comments that Nick is so funny
you're on point today buddy he's on
point every day stop talking I don't
like nepotism unless it's one of my
friends isn't that the whole point of
nothing
yeah I don't like nepotism unless one of
my friends hooked me up when did
nepotism help you in your life
never I think that's how I got this
that's why I don't like nepotism
are you kidding ah bar asked me I was
like hey do you want to do this oh yeah
then you just go on to prove to be the
funniest dude here okay nepotism yeah
what's the difference between nepotism
and networking
the way it's spelled
because like let's say like the
networking there's you get the job
because you network well and people like
you and then they think
there might be someone else more
qualified but I like you I'm going to
ask you you know what the difference
might be what it almost seems like
nepotism is the idea of the boss and
networking is the idea of the person
trying to get the position she may not
even wanted to do this but maybe that
person was like no you're gonna do this
it'll be good for you kind of deal she
looks like she doesn't you know like
nepotism sometimes yeah
because like nepotism would be like
let's say you're the mayor and then the
vice mayor is your aunt and then the of
the the the the County Treasurer is your
uncle and then like chief of police is
your cousin because you hooked them all
up with jobs yeah but it feels like
similar to what happened in uh what's
that one country where the uh
were the dudes there was like a coup and
then the powers shifted and then the
guy's in charge jacked all the money and
pieced out Mexico
oh yes yeah yeah Sri Lanka Sri Lanka
exactly yeah that to me is that's
nepotism because it's this Grand Masters
idea but he uses his family members to
keep the gains within the family yeah
because what's the difference between
nepotism and royal family I mean that's
just like autonomics well no that's
different because with the royal family
the blood was ordained by God oh yeah oh
it's chosen by God yeah so you can't
fight that you know what I mean when you
say something's chosen by God you can't
change it yeah you can't change no
matter who says it because he's like he
you know you're gonna you're gonna go
back on his word no nope no I'm not
gonna be the one I'm not even that
religious I'm not going to test it
because it's like it feels like nepotism
is done for the benefit of the person
like at the top it's like it benefits
that person ultimately like barbell
brigade's nepotism right because like
Geo's not supposed to be CEO
no Am I Wrong
oh man am I gonna get canceled Biden
Falls in that category then
kind of what if the allegations are true
he uses his son to do all the businesses
because the politician can't
I would say what's her name um Pelosi oh
well it's insider trading but what
Pelosi does is she's already in the
committee with all the business and all
the policy making she gets the News
tells her husband her husband makes the
stock trades he he balls out but she's
not doing anything illegal that's his
stock exactly yeah that's just teamwork
I think yeah which I you know what the
more I think about it that's just
teamwork that's not nepotism that's just
insider trading if I was Pelosi I'd do
the same [__] I think I think nepotism
is like hook hooking up your friends and
family with jobs that They Don't Really
Deserve especially if you're in a place
to influence like that one
um Chinese like producer film producer
who's Rich As [__] so he puts like his
daughter or whatever and like all these
random Blockbuster films and just has
like one line or just like next to these
like A-list Stars if she need any
American movies I think so is she in the
Meg
is it that movie sounds like somebody
who would be an adjacent State
basketball I know because I saw it
recently and I was like oh wait make one
or make two I think oh I saw the first
one okay make one was good make two I
don't know no it wasn't good I don't
know well I haven't even seen make but
it's from Beneath The Depths and I
thought the trailer was just like I
heard it still did a better box office
opening The Flash oh damn the flashlight
tank that hard huh yeah the flash tanked
I thought it'd be good they had a whole
TV series like I thought it was pretty
good I actually finished it but people
were just actively don't like the guy
right maybe Ezra Miller yeah
choking choking that that fan that video
is kind of that'll make a big difference
you know what it is too I feel like real
nepotism is when you hire your friends
and family so that when they're in those
positions they have to do what you say
so it's just an extension of your own
power it's like oh I got you this job
you gotta like listen to me but then if
somebody was networking and got that job
you don't have as much control because
they're probably actually like so if you
want more control nepotism is the way
honestly yeah that's why like isn't that
why like big businesses Corporation they
put like their own sons in charge of
this and that so that way it's just the
decision kind of comes from up here yeah
that makes sense so it's just efficient
yeah you guys you guys ever seen that
clip of Obama saying like yeah I mean if
I could just not be president and have
somebody just and I could pull the
strings you ever seen that clip that's
kind of tight
sounds like Biden to me
[Music]